entertainment like Canada yeah Canada my
favorite place on earth it's a great
place for a great place good good
friends brother brother brother Lee
friends with the United States
hopefully our bond will stay strong and
close over the year what's your fondest
memory my knee
oh really
do you want to yeah what was it like
Pacific Sharon Stone's yeah yes you
could maybe hear uh yeah yeah Basic
Instinct yeah I was thinking Sharon
Stone
instinct that was my fault entirely um
you look good both ways really well
fondest memory I mean what in 1993 is
that when the first Jurassic Park came
out long before you were born 1993 holy
cats yeah you know every memory in the
world 93 we do that I was a snip of a
whip of a snap of a River snapper heads
I stepped off the plane and Island close
by here and mr. Steven Spielberg who's a
kind of fun to see him up close
yeah his full of wonderment and chills
and thrills anyway you know and when I
pinched him to see if he was real they
dragged me off that room real quick
and I'll never forget that and then we
made that movie do you have any idea
what it would be
well I'd read the book yeah and the
script is a great book by Michael
Crichton and new that Steven Spielberg
you know pretty good could make a movie
yeah and but you know that was
pioneering technologies and Stan Winston
Dennis Muren who brought those dinosaurs
no no no you know I trusted that she was
in good hands and I try to do my little
part as a conic part well I tried to do
something with it and with Steve's help
and um and anyway yeah it caught on
people got a kick out of it
and why are we're still adding to the
story why was now the right time to come
back to
for me or movie for the movie to come
back sorry yeah movie - yeah well it's
the anniversary and the right the right
I don't know I'm guessing the right
elements cast wise and JAV ona you know
is a uniquely equipped person for this
moment on this movie and Colin Trevorrow
their talents are uniquely equipped and
so here they are and it all kind of came
together I guess
and the cast mm-hmm my god golly and you
know my character gets to say a smartish
thing or two about a couple of things
that relate to our current world have
all along but more and more with more
and more urgency yeah there is there so
when you're when you're addressing the
administration yes there's some
parallels with science obviously yeah is
there social commentary there is that
well I think they need us to be a little
provoked in our thinking and feeling yes
and I was just kind of being able to
deliver it yes I thought about nature
and being a humble student in alignment
with nature and being a student of
evolution real the facts of real
Darwinian evolution and and the glories
of science and human curiosity and
investigation the accomplishments of
science that's a wonderful thing it you
know I was happy to and to learn more
about but boy the people who would use
it and exploit it and misuse it for
profit and their own greed and
militarism shame on them and that's a
fight worth having in the movies and
worth having in life it's urgent
isn't it the health and and
responsibility toward our planet and
brother species and each other
yep what is Chris Pratt bring to a film
like this Chris Pratt is a brilliant
talented
vibrant lovely generous and sweet truly
good-hearted heroic person and so he
brings all of that authentic virile
rugged charm and and humor and
brilliance
to this movie as does Bryce Dallas
Howard hmm boy boy she's spectacular I
could go on I could gush about her it's
longer than we have plus all the other
people in the James Cromwell Geraldine
Chaplin we didn't move a couple movies a
while a long time ago she's so